>>
Today, we're lucky enough to have two authors
with us. They're both reporters at the Wall
Street Journal. Roger Thurow has been with
the journal as a foreign correspondent for
20 years and has reported on more than 60
countries including two dozen in Africa. Scott
Kilman has been the journal's leading agricultural
reporter. Together, they have teamed up to
produce a stream of page one stories that
have broken new ground in our understanding
of famine and food aid. Their stories on three
2003 famines were a finalist for the 2004
Pulitzer Prize in international reporting.
So please welcome them to discuss their book:
"Enough." Thank you.
>> THUROW: Thank you and thanks for coming.
I'm Roger, this is Scott. Scott, Roger. I
think our families know us as Roger, Scott,
Scott, Roger. They've become familiar with
us talking over the years. Thank you very
much for coming. This book, as Scott said,
we both have been deeply involved in issues
of hunger and even culture development and,
and what is known as food security for much
of the past decade in our reporting. So, this
book really encapsulates our passion about
the subjects, and figured if we didn't do
this book, our souls would never rest. And
so, I hope you, guys, all have copies and
that you enjoy it and learn something along
the way. Enough. Why enough? We have three
meanings in this one little word. One, first,
there's enough food in the world to feed everybody
which means the world is producing enough
food and has for the last number of decades,
for everybody to have sufficient, nutritional
sustenance. The second, enough is enough.
We brought hunger with us into the 21st century
and shame on us for doing so. The Green Revolution
was one of the great technological and scientific
achievements of the 20th century, and here
we are nine years into 21st century, not only
have we brought hunger with us, but we brought
it with us in an increasing amount. This year,
the number of hungry in the world and severely
malnourished is already soaring past one billion.
People, that's the highest level since before
the Green Revolution began in the 1960s and
the 1970s or when the Green Revolution kicked
in. And, for the first time since then, the
prevalence of hunger in the world is growing
which means the percentage of hungry people
among the population and those are, those
are just incredibly damning statistics that
for our age, you know, as you guys are all
intimately familiar with we've done so many
wonderful things, you know, wiring the world
for the Internet, Google and the marvelous
things you do but we still can't feed our
fellow man and that problem is getting even
worse. Three--there's enough people. You guys
that are gathered here, everybody involved
in the google.org; the process and efforts
to get involved in development issues and
help the hungry and the poor of the world.
And, you guys were all part of a bigger and
much larger movement, a Grassroots Movement
that is a foot particularly on the hunger
issues that comes from churches and synagogues,
and temples, and mosques, and university campuses,
small farms, big institutions from peasant
farmers in Africa to the leaders in Africa,
to CEOs and corporate headquarters in the
United States and then Europe. And to some
of the great philanthropists of the world:
Bill Gates, Warren Buffett; Howard Buffett,
Warren's son, who we'll see later, all intimately
involved in the hunger issue and really, are
really giving it a great momentum. Our mantra
in writing the book kind of constantly threw
the, I guess, it was through the report in
that, it inspired us to do this and the stories
for the Wall Street Journal. But while writing
the book, our mantra has been outrage and
inspire. We want, we want to outrage the readers
and also about that we brought hunger with
us into the 21st century, but also inspire
that we can actually do something about it,
and hunger is one of the great problems of
the world that can actually be conquered.
We have the tools, we have the intelligence,
we have the science to do it and it is something
that basically everybody can get involved
with. And, our own personal outrage, I guess,
began to stir after 9/11. When we started,
I was overseas; Scott was in Chicago covering
agriculture, domestically and the impact around
the world, and I was seeing things on the
ground in Africa. We started asking questions
about, well, what policies in the United States
and in Europe, government policies, the economic
policies really impact in the fact and particularly
negatively impact people in the developing
world, particularly the poor in the developing
world and in the most cases, they are farmers.
And so we started asking, one of the central
questions we were asking is why can't Africa
feed itself, and why did Africa miss out in
the Green Revolution? And in our reporting,
we came across something that Norman Borlaug
who is known as the father of the Green Revolution,
a very humble plant scientist from small town
Iowa and he won a Nobel Peace Prize in 1974,
his work on the Green Revolution. And, basically,
is known as perhaps the one human being who
has saved more lives than anybody else. In
his Nobel Peace Prize speech, it was the lecture
of the day afterwards; he said something that's
very prophetic and incredibly haunting when
you think about it in the context of the 21st
century. And he's saying this in 1970: "Man
can and must prevent the tragedy of famine
in the future instead of merely trying with
pious regret to salvage the human wreckage
of the famine as he has so often done in the
past. We will be guilty of criminal negligence
without extenuation if we permit future famines."
Criminal negligence. The light went off with
Scott and myself, that's what we are. We're
basically criminal, we're basically crime
reporters because what were we doing as we
were reporting about hunger is we were investigating
one of the great crimes of our, of our time;
that was even five or six years ago, and now
if you bring it back or advance it, here we
are even further and the hunger situation
is getting worse. The crime continues, it's
from, you know, our own neglect as Borlaug
said, "It's good intentions gone bad," and
we try to get on, into all of this in the
book. And then the Ethiopian famine of 2003
was another turning point for us and also
for the greater fight against hunger. That
famine in 2003 in Ethiopia was worse than
the one in 1984; I don't know how old all
of your guys are. The famine of 1984 was a
milestone for, say people of our generation,
it was kind of one of the first global events,
the Live Aid concerts put together by Bob
Geldof, Bono was part of that, all sorts of
the bands in Britain, Ireland, and the United
States with a huge global concert, sang "We
Are World, Do They Know It's Christmas," raised
a lot of money, a lot of awareness for the
famine in Ethiopia in 1984. All sorts of pious
statements as Borlaug had referred to, never
again, it shouldn't happen again, a million
people died in that famine in Ethiopia. Well,
here we were in 2003, 19 years later, famine
once again hit in Ethiopia and worse than
the one in 1984. Worse in the sense of more
people being on the doorstep of starvation.
In 1984, there were maybe 10 to 12 million
that were on the doorstep of starvation; more
people died, it was a communist government.
There wasn't--the relief efforts were already
there in the country but, about 10 to 12 million
on the verge of starvation and needed to be
fed. In 2003, it was more than 14 million
people, so there were actually more people
in 2003 that were on the doorstep of starvation.
What happened? There in lies the tale of our
book. It was Borlaug's criminal neglect come
to life or come to death. And, we--as I said,
it becomes the core of our book and we will
now go on a brief journey back to the famine
of 2003, and again, remember the mantra outrage
and inspire. The first part of what we're
going to show you is to outrage, it's also
the first part of the book then we'll do--we'll
come to some of the inspiration that's when
Scott will take over because he's the more
inspirational of us; I'm the one harboring
all these outrage over the situation. If you
spend too much time with me, you'll think,
you'll obviously know the same thing. So,
the scene of the crime as Borlaug says, here
we are. These are emergency feeding tents
in Boricha, Ethiopia up on the highlands.
>> KILMAN: You took this picture...
>> THUROW: I was there, I took these pictures
and a number of these that are coming. Interest
in explaining of what happened. Obviously,
the kids are in horrible shape. The one on
the right, the left, in the white shirt--I'm
looking backwards, is--the one in the white
shirt is Hagiorso Katayma [ph]. He was five
years old at that time and was brought in
by his father who's sitting behind him, he
weighed only 27 pounds at five years old,
showing all the signs of, of horrible severe
malnutrition, the swollen stomach, the swollen
limbs and the swollen head from the various
manifestations of malnutrition from lack of
protein. And as you can see, he and the boy
next to him or the child next to him, that's
a boy or girl are being held up by their fathers,
they're propped between the legs, their fathers
have their hands on them because they're so
weak, they can't even, they can't even sit
up. The interesting thing is that their parents,
the men behind them are peasant farmers in
Ethiopia. They each have maybe, you know,
one or two acres of land. The year before,
they were carrying to the same market village
in Ethiopia, bags of their surplus grain.
They had had their best harvest ever in the,
the 2001 harvest season and 2002, and at that
stage--and it was all across the country,
it wasn't only these guys, but it was Ethiopia
had had its biggest harvest in history because
since 1984 famine, the push had been on in
Ethiopia and elsewhere in Africa to produce,
produce, produce, to ramp up and increase
the production of grains as quickly and as
mightily as possible. That they did and they
had great success. So these guys in 2001-2002
are carrying this huge hundred, hundred pound
bags of surplus grain to the market, they're
overjoyed. They finally have surplus crops,
a great income for the family. Well, what
happened? They came to the market and because
of the surplus that the whole country had,
the prices collapsed by 80% across Ethiopia.
These guys ended up losing--the price that
they got was less than their cost of production,
less than the cost of the fertilizer, less
than the cost of the calculated cost of their
labor of the wagon that they had to use and
things and so, these guys lost money; they
reacted like farmers anywhere else. In the
United States, we're from Illinois. We went
to the University of Iowa. We grew up surrounded
in the cornfields and the wheat fields in
the Midwest. The farmers lose money, they
changed their tactics. They'll plant different
crops, they'll use cheaper inputs. These guys,
the next year, what do they do? They cut back
on their use of fertilizer. Fertilizer use
in Ethiopia fell 27% the next year; this is
planting season for 2002-2003. They stopped
using the better hybrid seeds; they took whatever
seeds they had in the back of their huts.
They knew they were going to get, they weren't
as good as seeds. The use of hybrid seeds
in Ethiopia fell 70%. That year as farmers
tried to cut production, some of the bigger
farmers took thousands of acres out of production.
They shut off their irrigation systems because
they were too expensive that they couldn't
afford. And, they all knew they were going
to get less production because they were using
less fertilizer, not as good as seeds, but
the calculation that these gentlemen made
was, that's okay, because we had a surplus
production. What did it do? We actually lost
money on it. We'll cut back our expenses.
Okay, we'll grow less food but as long as
we have enough food to feed our families,
that's great. That's our goal as peasant farmers,
that'll be great. What happened? Drought hit
the country which it does on a regular basis.
Everybody looked to the heavens for rain,
rain wasn't coming; it was very sporadic.
That impacted their crops, the production
which they thought would be lower, fell even
more. Hunger spread across the country, tips
in the famine across the country. These two
gentlemen, Tasfia [ph], the man in the brown
shirt behind his son Hagiorso [ph], they are
carrying their children to the market where
the year before they had carried their huge
surplus grains of wheat. In their success
came their failure, from feast came famine.
The whole of economics of farming for these
guys stood on their heads. It's a horrible
and cruel paradox that during the boost to
push production in Ethiopia and elsewhere
in Africa but, particularly, in Ethiopia,
the markets were ignored. The markets failed
before the weather did. And so the lesson
of all this is markets matter. Here are some
other people in that same, that same feeding
tent, and again, out of their success came
failure, feast led the famine; one of the
cruelest ironies that one can see in Africa.
Wow. What's this? Also in Ethiopia, not far
from the emergency feeding tents maybe a couple
of hours drive. This is an Ethiopian farmer
and grain trader. He's standing in the warehouse
and this is, this is what is stacked up in
front of him are stacks of corn, wheat, beans,
peas, lentils that had come from the surplus
of the two previous harvest. Why is this here?
Because these guys had some warehouse facilities,
they figured if they store it, it'll help
support prices a little bit. If all of this
grain that they had stored in these warehouses
went on the market, the prices instead of
collapsing 80%, you know, would've gone down
even further or would have taken such a long
time to recover, so these guys held it in
the warehouses. There's another picture. Where
these guys are is in the town of Nazareth,
in a little bit east of the capital of Addis
Ababa. Two blocks away is where the road from
Djibouti where is the nearest port runs to
the capital of Addis, that's the same road
where all the Food Aid that comes, that were
streaming in the country to feed this 14 million
people that were hungry. The bulk of the Food
Aid or at least over 50% of the Food Aid that
year was coming from the United States. So
here comes all these grain and corn and wheat
and soybeans and all of this Food Aid from
the United States running pass these warehouses
in Ethiopia, they're full of grain. Again,
all the way up to the ceiling, a staggering
sight in a country that is experiencing famine.
Why was this happening? Because of the US
Food Aid policy. It's mandated in the US that
we have to ship American grown food for Food
Aid around the world. We can't use cash from
the federal government budget to buy this
food that's already sitting there and would
be a huge incentive and a huge market for
the farmers of Ethiopia and elsewhere in Africa
if somebody would come in, particularly, the
United States and buy their grain in a time
of, in a time of famine. So if you stood outside
the warehouses and stood inside in their parking
lots, you could literally feel the rumble
of the trucks laden with the big, huge double
wide trucks laden with Food Aid from the United
States rumbling pass their warehouses full
of Ethiopian food to basically feed the starving
Ethiopians and these guys are wondering, well,
how come, they're not sending our food or
using our food? This guy, German Mamente [ph]
he climbed to the--climbed to the top of his,
one of stack, he said, "Roger, take my picture
and put this picture on the Wall Street Journal
with the caption, 'Please send food, Ethiopians
are starving, we have no food in Ethiopia.'"
It's terribly ironic. He laughed hilariously
at that in a fit of gallous humor; that basically
encapsulates one of the, another of the horrible
ironies. These guys then got together, a number
of the commercial farmers and traders and
they wrote a letter to their government. The
Food Aid coming to the country is great, saving
a lot of people, our fellow Ethiopians, but
first can you tell the donors and the government
in sending the Food Aid, "Please buy our grain
first because if we don't sell our grain;
one, we're not going to have room to store
it next year and two, we're not going to have
any money to buy the, the crops to the farmers
in this planting season, in this, in the following
places." We're going to end up in the same
situation. There is going to be another, there
is going to be another lack of food, prices
are going to collapse, the farmers are going
to lose all incentive again to grow. At the
same time, in the United States, so I'm in
Ethiopia talking with these guys about this,
Scott's talking to farmers in the United States
and, and the folks in the White House. A group
of American farmers at the same time, led
by the Wheat Association was writing a letter
to the White House--it's Clinton White House
right, on 2003, no?
>> KILMAN: Bush.
>> THUROW: Bush. Bush's White House, saying
please include more American food and particularly
American--in American Food Aid shipments because
we've had a surplus and a great harvest in
the United States and there's pressure on
our wheat prices in the United States. "Please
send the food overseas in Food Aid." The conclusion
on the Ethiopians and it's hard to dispute
with them is American farmers need starving
Ethiopians; two letters, two sets of farmers,
exact opposite purposes at the same time in
the midst of a famine. These two guys, lentil
farmers in Ethiopia, they are standing--they're
in all their sartorial splendor, and typical
dress, they're wearing rags--this stuff is
all kind of put together. Scott will talk
about this later, most of the farmers in Africa
and, and in the developing world and particularly
in Africa, are women. It's just coincidental
that some of these photos are men. These guys
were on the road, the same Djibouti to Addis
road where the Food Aid trucks are running
pass. I'm talking to them, a huge convoy of
Food Aid trucks go by and there's a little
bit of cargo that basically drips out of the
trucks and kind of scatters along the road.
The trucks go pass; we all run into the road,
these guys are particularly curious "What
is this, what feel out?" Again, I said these
guys are lentil farmers, they bend over and
they picked it up and it's lentils and they
said "Where is this coming from?" and I said
"Well, based on the markings of the trucks,
on the bags, on the trucks, I think it's coming
from the United States" and they said "Well,
why are they sending lentils to America, or
why are they sending lentils to Ethiopia?
Don't they know in America that we grow lentils
in Ethiopia?" I said "No, I don't think they
know in America that you grow lentils in Ethiopia
and that you should grow a surplus of lentils
that they can export some." And so, again
setting up the huge irony and contradiction
that it's almost, you know coals to New Castle
in the midst of a famine and Ethiopia had
food from its previous shares of surplus production
we're sending in that. What this also represents
is the neglect that Borlaug talked about,
a huge part of that was the huge fall off
in development aid for agriculture and agriculture
development, and particularly in Africa. And
in Ethiopia, and it was not only by the United
States but by all the western countries and
the rich governments of the world. In Ethiopia
in 2003 and it's a stunning set of numbers.
There was $500 million in this American Food
Aid that was coming to Ethiopia that year,
$500 million in food from America that was
coming to Ethiopia. That same year in 2003,
U.S. agriculture development aid to Ethiopia
was less than $5 million. Less than $5 million
to help them grow food so that they wouldn't
be hungry to begin with; $500 million in food
to say "That's okay, we'll feed you." Again,
a damning statistics, why are we doing that?
What's wrong with our policies? Why aren't
we helping the Ethiopians to grow as much
food as possible and to feed themselves as
opposed to us sending our food to feed them
when they do become hungry? This man with
the scarf in his head, on a turban, it was
a very hot day, it was cooling him off is
Tasfahum Valijud [ph], Tasfahum [ph] means
"be hope" in the Amharic language. When I
saw him in the midst of--this is in 2003 again.
Mr. "Be Hope" had basically lost all hope.
He's standing beside the Red River which is
one of the tributaries of the Blue Nile. The
Blue Nile is one of the great waterways of
Africa. It gathers steam and a tremendous
power runs over gorges and cascades and basically
500 miles that it runs through Ethiopia and
the Sudan, Sudan connects the White Nile which
is coming up from the great lakes region of
Central Africa and together they form in Sudan--in
Khartoum in Sudan and then they form the great
Nile which runs through, up through Egypt.
Tasfahum at this stage, he's got the water
running right pass him. His farm, his little
plot of an acre or two which is right to the
side of the picture, is bone dry. There's
nothing growing because of the drought, whatever
he had planted has died. He's been on Food
Aid for nine months at this time. Well, the
Food Aid from America is streaming into the
country, and I asked him "Well, why aren't
you taking the water from the Red River running
in front of you right by your feet and irrigating
your land?" and he said "You know, well, we
thought about that." You know, he kind of
fixes me with a gaze, you know, we're not
dumb, we thought about that. We have tried
to do that; the government basically comes
by and says "You can't do that." Why? The
water belongs in Egypt. What happened was,
is that Ethiopia had the great fortune of
never being colonized by a European power--one
of the rare African countries for that to
happen. Ethiopia also had the great misfortune
of not being colonized by a great European
power because when the European powers came
together and the councils of Europe and said
"Well, what should we do about Africa?" They
then divvied up water rights and the Brits
were in charge of--were the colonial powers
in Egypt and Sudan at that time and they said,
"Water of Egypt or the water of the Nile must
be for our cotton plantations and the granaries
in Sudan and the granaries in Egypt. The downstream
users, we should have the right of the Nile
water usage." There's nobody in Ethiopia to
stand up and say "Well, what about us?" Eighty-five
percent of the water that runs through Egypt
and basically brings 8 million acres of land
in Egypt and of the Sahara Desert to bloom
and to produce a whole cornucopia of food,
eighty-five percent of the water in Egypt,
in the Nile and in the canals comes from Ethiopia
and from the highlands of Ethiopia where they
usually get pretty good rain. It runs to the
Blue Nile or through some of the tributaries
that run into Sudan or in the canyon connect
with the White Nile or the great Nile and
itself. And, so 85% of the water of the Nile
which is irrigating 8 million acres back in
2003, in Ethiopia, less than 500,000 acres
are irrigated. So all the Ethiopian water
is being taken, is being irrigated and irrigating
crops somewhere else and producing food elsewhere
and not here. And one of the great cruel ironies
is, is that the land that feeds the Nile can't
feed itself, and it was a screwed up system
of geopolitics that allowed that to happen.
Now, this is an Egyptian farmer. He's 100
miles from the Nile. He's way out in the desert.
He's at the last stop in the desert that still
gets Nile water. If he wants to expand his
farm, he's got to expand the canal system.
This guy, I think he had 60 acres of a whole
array of peppers and lettuce and cucumbers
and tomatoes that were grown in hothouses.
Some grow corn, and wheat grown in his fields
and he had a lot of cattle, these are water
buffalo calves, they're being showered. He
says "Well, happy cattle are fatter cattle."
He sells them for a higher price. The water
that is showering them is Ethiopian water.
This guy is Food Aid. They can't grow, that's
their water, runs into Nile. This man using
the water that perhaps is running by this
guy's feet, Tasfahum [ph] feet water his cattle.
Again, outrage. This is 2002, now we're in
Mali in West Africa, subsidies issue of the
American farm subsidies. These guys are West
African cotton farmers. They are, you know,
dressed in rags. They do all their planting
by hand. They are walking behind their two
draft oxen; they're not mechanized, whatsoever.
I got to remember, this is an American cotton
farm in Mississippi. Now these two pictures
were taken on the same day. I was in Mali,
Scott was in the Mississippi Delta and it's
the same day. These guys, the water, the rain
just started to fall, they figuring, "Well,
the rain is coming, time to go prepare for
the planting season." I think they were doing
the same in Mississippi on that day. This
is Ken Hood. He was the head of the American
Cotton Counsel and Cotton Association, whatever
it's called. In 2002, was the Farm Bill that
President Bush signed, and again, he signed
it five, six, seven months after 9/11 where
President Bush was asking the question that
he said was on the minds of a whole bunch
of Americans at the time, and rightfully so,
why do they hate us so much? So they started
the whole round of World Trade talks called
the Development Round. How do we make the
World Trade benefit people in the developing
world? They have the Monterey Conference in
Monterey, Mexico where everybody pledged,
we're going to increase our development aid
to the developing world. That, I think, was
in Doha, it was in November of 2001, Monterey
in March or April of 2002. In May of 2002
comes U.S. Farm Bill which Bush signs, raising
subsidies for American farmers and particularly
for American cotton farmers. The first person,
President Bush turns around to shakes hands
with after signing the bill is Mr. Ken Hood
because and he has a big smile on his face
because his subsidies were greatly increased
and the farmers are the potential subsidies
that they could get. No subsidies for these
farmers in Mali and the government at the
same time was telling them that their price
for their cotton is going to be cut by 5,
10, 15% that year because there was a glut
of cotton in the world market. The world market,
the, all the cotton that basically is grown
in the United States, we don't have a cotton
industry anymore, we don't make t-shirts or
underwear, and it drives down the prices.
The Mali government was able to pay less to
its own cotton farmers. So, if you look at
these two people and you'd wonder, "Wow, who
should get the--who should get the aid from
the government, who should get the subsidies?"
This guy should--does he need subsidies? That's
the question that we address in the book;
that's the outrage section--inspiration Dr.
Borlaug?
>> KILMAN: Well, now they're all bummed out.
>> THUROW: Now they're all bummed out. You're
thinking, what's going on? So, people should
be simply outraged as it is promises the world,
that's driving the hunger problem.
>> KILMAN: Roger has talked about the Green
Revolution and this is all before your time.
Most of, most, everybody's in the wrong time.
But, with the Green Revolution was in the
1960s and 1970s, hunger and famine was a problem
mostly of Asia, that's where the epicenter
was India and Pakistan. And this man had been--lucky
coincidence, had been working in Mexico trying
to develop better types of wheat for the poor
farmers of Mexico. And, what was happening
was that the farmers of Mexico would grow
their crop and would be wiped out by diseases.
So, he was given the job of trying to find
wheat plants that could resist this disease
and he was successful. He was just a--I won't
call him a simple scientist but he was--he
didn't start of thinking of himself as a humanitarian.
He was given a scientific problem and he pursued
it, try to figure out how to solve it and
he did. As it happened the way that he solved
it was he came up with a new way of breeding
wheat plants. Mexico is unique because there's
actually two places in Mexico where you can
go grow wheat at different times of the year.
You can grow wheat continuously in Mexico
just but in different parts. So he had to
figure out, you know, how do I, how do I stay
ahead over this disease that keeps evolving
and keeps changing. Every time I come up with
a new wheat plant, you know, this fungus evolves
quickly and it will destroy the wheat plant,
so he had to speed up planting, he has to
speed up breeding and he did by breeding,
by figuring out that he could breed two cycles.
In Mexico, you could actually two wheat crops
in Mexico in a year but that meant traveling
more than a thousand miles back and forth
on trucks. You need to harvest at one place,
take the seed, travel up to Northwest Mexico,
plant it there, see how well it did, pick
the best ones, bring it down to around Mexico
cities, so he speed up the breeding process.
In the process of doing that, he came up with
a type of wheat plant nobody expected. It
was a type of wheat plant that could grow
anywhere in the world. Most plants are very
sensitive to their environment, only grow
in a very unique place because the length
of daylight, the climate and the soil. But,
unintentionally, he came up with a super right--a
super wheat plant that would grow anywhere.
So, when the India and Pakistan were having
their famines, he was the guy who had the
seeds to plant a crop that could grow in India
and Pakistan and it worked, and the wheat
production soared in India and Pakistan so
that by, you know, the 1960s--I have to look
at the book but I think, in the late 1960s,
20% of all the wheat that was grown in the
United States was being shipped to India for
Food Aid, 20%, one in five bushels. By the
mid 1970s, India could feed itself. And, by
the late 1970s, India actually had excess
stock piles and in the '80s or '90s or some
years where India was actually exporting wheat.
People still think of India, and there's still
a lot of poverty, still a lot of hunger in
India but there weren't famines anymore. And
it was, it happened just because he was a
stubborn guy, and he was given a very specific,
scientific problem and he solved it and a
coincidence, he had the tool that could help
India and Pakistan; on a footnote, this is
Norman Borlaug. He won the Nobel Peace Prize
in 1970 because of this, he was coined the
Green Revolution. What happened, what he was
able to do to stop the famines in India and
Pakistan in the 1960s or 1970s, the seeds
spread throughout Asia, throughout Latin America
and it was an amazing time in the '70s and
the '80s--something very unusual happened.
If you put it in an economic function--what
happens is that the per capital availability
of grain around the world actually grew which
nobody expected. Everybody thought that population,
as Malthis said population grows faster than
food production, and he had more to do with
anybody else to shovel that. We don't have
to be doomed to buy that idea. You can actually
make more food available to everybody even
as the population is growing. But, it's interesting
because he's probably the most obscure Nobel
Peace Prize winner you'll never hear about.
He never made a lot of money, never patented
any of his inventions,
and if he had, his techniques are not used
by a lot of SIG companies, biotechnology companies,
he'd be a very wealthy man but he lives in
a two-bedroom house in Dallas and lives very
humbly. He's now 95 years old. I was just
with him a couple of weeks ago doing a video
for the wsj.com, that will hopefully run this
weekend. And, here's this guy--what fascinated
me about him was that, when you write a book
about hunger, it's a pretty daunting task
because you start off and you think, well,
there are a million problems, it's an unsolvable
problem, there are a million problems. How
can--you know, how could you find any kind
of hope in this problem? And you look at Norman
Borlaug and you realize well, one person can
make a difference. He didn't intend to make
a difference but just doing his job and doing
his work, he came across something was pretty
miraculous and he made a difference, what's
the next [INDISTINCT]. Some of my notes in
the--so I'm to supposedly be the inspirational
one, a part of what we're talking. So, the
first half of the book basically lays out
the problem. It makes the argument that hunger
is a solvable problem and the second part
of the book focuses on people who are actually
doing something about it. So, Norman Borlaug
is sort of the grand example of somebody who
can make a difference; who can still inspire
people. One of the people who's doing, working
now in Africa is Howard Buffett. His last
name is a lot better known. He's the son of
Warren Buffet, the eldest son of Warren Buffet.
He's one of the wealthiest men in the world.
You know, while Warren is an expert stack
picker and loves to sit in an office, he sits
in an office and goes through the financial
data. Howard didn't want that kind of life;
he wanted to be a farmer, he like grew up
in Omaha. He--as it turned out, you know,
in his farming life, he got more involved
in political issues and agricultural issues,
and ended up working for some corporations.
Archer Daniels Midland, he was on the board
of Kanegra, and the Coca-cola Enterprises,
other companies like this. On one of his business
trips to Africa--go backward--no, no. On one
of his business trips to Africa, he took a
camera with him, and he is sort of conservationist.
He was very interested in the environment.
So, when he went Africa on a business trip,
he was interested in cheetahs, and you know,
gorillas, and saving the gorilla which is
all good stuff, and he had somebody supporting
that kind of thing. But it was in 2000, he
went to Northern Ghana to a town called Tamale,
you've been there, right? I've been there.
In Northern Ghana, and he was being--I think
he was accompanied by World Vision, one of
the NGOs there, just trying to show him, you
know, different issues he should get involved
with. He's walking through a hospital and
he sees this girl laying in a bed. And he--she's,
basically, she's starving to death. She has
meningitis and she had something, she's malnourished
but...
>> THUROW: Malaria.
>> KILMAN: Meningitis and malaria. Her body
couldn't fight off diseases, and she dies
a few days after this picture was taken. And
this picture changed his life. He took this
picture, it's really--it's in our book, it's
interesting to me because she's looking right
at him through the viewfinder. And he's a
father of five, and he sees this, and he told
me--one of the first times I had to set down
my camera, I couldn't take any more pictures.
And he ended up talking to the mother through
a translator, and something happened, he sort
of having--he started an epiphany that he
realized that the issue that he'd been concerned
about in Africa, conservation and the environment,
protecting endangered animals and hunger were
linked. But one of the reasons that the animals
were endangered in Africa and the environment
was endangered in Africa, it was because of
the way that poor people were having to scrounge
for food. That they were cutting down the
forest to find any kind of acre land that
they could plant; that they didn't have the
means to grow enough food on their own land.
That they had to keep moving after they grow
out in some land and do a bad job of it, exhaust
the soil, they have to move on to somewhere
else, it's called slash and burn farming.
A little while after he took this picture,
he was flying in a plane over the, near the
Serengeti and he was taking pictures of the
thundering herds of the wildebeest and zebra.
But, on the flight, he noticed the fires in
the distance and they flew over, and they
realized that the farmers are burning down
the forest to try to make room to grow, and
the light went off in his head, and he realized
that we can't, you really can't handle the
conservation issue, you can't make your progress
in conservation unless you help people feed
themselves. And so, his focus changed from
being primarily, conservationist to being
someone who wants to help people in Africa
farm better. Now, he's an unusual man because
he's a farmer, but he also has access to enormous
wealth. His--you've all heard, you probably
have all heard the story when Warren Buffet
gave about $40 billion dollars of his money
to the Gates Foundation. He also carved out
a fraction of that and it was 1.5 billion
over 20 years, it was carved out for his three
children, and Howard is one of his three children.
So, now he has about--depending on the stock
price is, he has, you know, between $38 and
$50 million dollars to spend a year on his
hunger fighting projects in Africa. And he's
interesting because he really does it on his
own, he doesn't have a big staff. You see
the gouge on his shoulder, the big scar, that's
the way, he's always like that. I mean, this
guy is actually on the dirt scrounging around,
falls off stuff just like me all the time.
You can't see it but there's a cheetah scar,
there's a cheetah bite scar on his right hand;
he almost got eaten by a polar bear once too.
>> THUROW: Not in Africa?
>> KILMAN: Not in Africa. No. Yeah, he hasn't
been that successful. But the point of him
is, you know, here's this guy who could have
a very easy life. I mean, he has access to
enough money to make any of us happy, and
he's made the decision that what he wants
to do with his expertise which is farming,
and with his unusual family situation is spend
it in Africa on the poorest people. So, what
the--I don't know, if you all see any people
in that, he's actually on a cornfield in Burundi,
right? Back in the, earlier this year and
he's actually talking with women in this village
about very, very simple things which is "Why
it's a good thing to plant your rows, why
plant your corn on a straight line?" I mean,
he isn't introducing hi-tech farming here.
It's very, very simple things like, you know,
things that we knew 150 years ago, or 100
years in the United States, it just the very
fundamentals of farming to make your farming
operation more efficient. And again he--so,
he's an example of--you know, just one person
who's trying to make a difference in Africa,
and then, this next?
>> THUROW: Another one person, one of the
extraordinary women of Africa, Elayne Gabramado
[ph]. She is an Ethiopian--throughout the
famine in two decades before, in 1984, she
was a student at Cornell University, it was
in the lunch room, ate for lunch or dinner,
and a food fight broke out, and she stood
on the table in the middle of the famine in
1984, stood up on a table and said, stop wasting
food, people in my country are starving. She
thought about that, it was kind of a watershed
moment for her that she basically then dedicated
her life and her studies and her career as
an agricultural economist or market economist,
to basically straighten out the markets in
African agriculture. As we pointed out in
the other pictures, the markets failed before
the weather did in the 2003 famine. That became
the catalyst for her to start the Ethiopian
commodity exchange; there she is ringing the
bell. The little thing is--the monitors are
behind her. It's one of the first days of
trading of it, has a great accomplishment
in Africa that actually have a commodity exchange
is one of the few in Africa, north of the
Limpopo in South Africa. And, again, one person
really determined crying in the wilderness
for all those years. Finally, you know--gets
her chance and then sets this up.
>> KILMAN: One thing I'm going to explain
about--don't go back. One thing I'll explain
about commodity exchange why it's important,
we're based in Chicago so, you know we buy
the commodity exchanges. The commodity exchanges
started in the United States back in 1860s
and it was a great benefit to American farmers
because they had the problem then the Ethiopian
farmers have now, they have a good crop, everybody
brings it at the same markets, at the same
time, prices collapsed. When a commodity is
exchanged, particularly, the future is exchanged,
it's a way for farmer to lock in a price into
the future, so that they don't have to take
the price that they're getting that day. It's
a market where everybody's competing for what
price they want to pay in the future. They
want to know who's going to deliver a crop
to them, so an exchange sounds really mundane,
it's immensely important to the farmers. This
is a picture that I took in Northern Ghana,
and the reason we included this one is an
example of where--there's a group of women,
he was in Bulgo [ph] Katanga where they--I
love that name--they're a group of women who
lived in this town and they were all mothers,
middle aged women, and some Christian NGO
came in and started a literacy program for
them and they all learned how to read. Well,
in the process of learning how to read, they
sort of bonded together and they realized,
now we know how to read what are we going
to do with that? How would it make our lives
better? And they were smart enough to realize
that what they had growing around them that
was, you know, basically, like wild food were
shea nuts, shea nut trees. And in ladies'
cosmetics--are there men's cosmetics? Ladies'
cosmetics, shea nut is, you know, used in,
you know, in skin care or skin cream. So,
they realized, well, gee, we have something
valuable, why don't we make shea nut butter,
and someday will buy our shea nut butter.
So, actually, they got a little money, a little
bit of money from an NGO and they built this,
this little cement block house, and that's--this
is basically shea nut butter processing facility.
And they collected these nuts, they cracked
them, they take the meat out, they heat them
up, they blend them together and they end
up being in these, I think once these are
filled in, the other ones end up having the
shea in it, great idea. The problem is the
world's worse business plan. I listened to
their story and I thought, you know, it be
a good example for the book about people trying
to better themselves, but they did everything
backwards. They realized this, this, well,
we have something that's viable, let's sell
it. They never figured--they never asked themselves
who's going to but it? You know, in the United
States they would say "Gee, will somebody
buy something that I have?" You know, I want
to make money from this, is anyone going to
buy it? You ask that first. So, I show up
and they're asking me, "Chief, do you know
anybody who buys this stuff?" They have buckets,
and what sort of--the parallel to me, what
sort of struck me is that, you know, in the
United states, maybe in United States but
in other places, if they don't have an access
to the Internet, you now, in the United States,
you're an apple farmer or carrot farmer or
somebody would say, "Gee, I got something
that, you know, organic. I'm going to sell
it over the Internet, at least there's a way
for me to find and do some research and find
out who wants Shea nut butter? Who'll buy
it from me, who can send an email to this
and say, "Gee, we have it." And as--I actually
think to myself, you know, gosh, if I had--if
I wasn't doing what I was doing I'd go in
the Internet and start pitching and say, "You
know, I know these farmers in Ghana who sell
fare trade and organic Shea nut butter." That
would be great, and you could put it, you
know, from Ghana, you know, help these people.
But, they didn't have that tool to reach the
rest of the world. So, one of the reasons
I include in these pictures, you know, it
strikes me that, you know, what you guys do,
you know, the Internet allows people to, if
they only had access to it, is to reach the
world in a way that they couldn't have reached
it to five years ago or 10 years ago.
>> THUROW: They could have Googled Shea nut
butter.
>> KILMAN: Yeah. As I did when I got back,
I find out, you know, Japanese companies want
Shea nut butter.
>> THUROW: Yeah, so, I mean, they're genius
enough to develop this Rube Goldberg type
of contraption, and some of their inventions
are quite, are quite remarkable.
>> KILMAN: So, this--we include this picture
because, what we're really writing about this
is how generations of people are damned just
because of where they grow up. The fact that--if
you believe that all life--anybody's life
is valuable, and equally valuable, she doesn't
have a chance. The reasons she doesn't have
a chance it's because, I think I was in Togo
and Benin now, I think she's probably seven
years old, so hard to tell how old the kids
are because they're so tiny. They don't get
a chance to grow to their full potential but
her life is going to be hauling water. That
stone on her head, her job and her family
is to haul water. Flip to the next picture--oh,
go back, I'm sorry, I thought I had another
picture there.
>> THUROW: No.
>> KILMAN: But she's got the stone that she
bounces on her head and her job is to go on
in the morning, walk in to this village and
collect water. Walk along the road and bring
it back to her family which could be kilometers.
One day the SUV I was traveling in broke down
and there's a hill and it was like a 135 degrees,
and I thought we were completely isolated
and deserted and nobody was going to find
us, and I kept seeing shimmers out in the
distance, and I realized that they were like
little girls. They don't--they saw strangers
on the road so they're weren't going to walk
by us. So, they were walking about a half
of kilometer, a quarter of kilometer away
just carrying water back and forth, just like
that. The difference that her family, and
she's from a farming family, they barely make
enough to survive through they year. If they
were able to grow enough on their land not
just to feed themselves, but to have something
more to grow, they could have afford to pay
the fees where she could go to school, and
she wouldn't be hauling water.
>> THUROW: Which is this, this is a school
in Mali, and this is where she should be.
These are, majority are girls, and this is
a school feeding program and one of the great
things that's also great for the, it's a great
incentive for African farmers, for somebody
to buy, the World Food Program, Howard Buffet,
others involved, the Gates Foundation, to
buy the crops that the African farmers themselves
grow, give them a market, can keep the price
up, gives them incentive to grow as much as
they can, and it feeds the school children
of Africa. If the parents of this girl, if
she could go to school and bring--and be fed
in school, and then for a lot of the girls
they give them a monthly ration to take home
of both food and cooking oil. If her parents,
if she could do that and bring that home,
her parents would say, "Your time is more
valuable to us as an economic commodity, you
go to school. You'll get fed in school that's
one less mouth for us to feed and you will
bring food home for the family." So school
feeding is one of the great things of African,
and also a lot of people can make a difference.
>> KILMAN: We'll just move the slides if you
have any questions. We've been prattling on,
you may have any questions?
>> First of all, thanks a lot for coming;
I really enjoyed your talk. So, you set up
this talk basically saying that the Green
Revolution is this great thing and if only,
you know, the rest of the world had access
to it. But, there's been a lot of discourse
lately that [INDISTINCT] Green Revolution
is a lot of, cause of a lot of ecological
problems that we have and it's not clear to
me at least that the Green Revolution everywhere
is necessarily a good thing. So, somebody
who cares about both the issues of starvation
and also the issue of the environment which
seems also ultimately relatively troubling.
Do I have to choose between these two things
right, like, do I have to say, "All right,
put off the environment and say green evolution
for everybody and then every one eats or can
I have them both?"
>> KILMAN: Okay. So that's a great question.
The Green Revolution of Asia in 1960s and
1970s isn't what we want and isn't the Green
Revolution that would work in Africa today
and it's a different Green Revo--different
Green Revolution. Green Revolution is actually
a very loaded term because it gets associated
with the heavy use of pesticides and fertilizers.
There was a lot of--when they started it in
the 1960s and '70s, they didn't know enough--they
didn't as much as they know now. So, what
had had happened there, you know, farmers
who have been starving one year, they have
a big crop because they start putting fertilizer
on it. And so, they said, "Gee, that was great,
more would be better." And they put too much
on, and they got into the water ways. Since
that time, we've learned a lot more about
how not to waste fertilizer. I mean, the farmers
quickly realized that, you know, if you put
on too much, you're wasting it, why spend
that money on it? So, in Africa, we've gotten
to the point now where you--I think you could
much more micro-manage the amount of fertilizer
and the insecticides that you use, that you
can avoid those problems or a lot of those
problems. But I also say this that what happened,
you know, in the 1960s and 1970s, the famine
stopped other than North Korea. You know,
famine stopped in Asia. If you--if we were
talking about this in 1960s and 1970s, you
would think that were be the best thing that
could possibly happen. Well, now, in hindsight,
we can look back and we're not worried about
famine in Asia anymore. So, we can worry about
things like, "Gee, they were excesses that
occurred. It's--what you're arguing about
is which is worse, problems of scarcity or
problems of abundance? You know, problems
of scarcity are a lot harder to fix than problems
of abundance. So now, we have more food in
Asia. Now we can be better growing it. We
don't have to worry about producing such massive
amount so quickly. We can be more scientific,
more surgical about how we do it. In Africa,
I wouldn't want, I wouldn't want this--you
would want to do the same type of agricultural
development that you did in Asia; it's a different,
much more complicated. Asia has a lot of lands,
you could grow two crops in Asia and have
a huge effect. You grow a lot more rice and
wheat in Asia and have a huge effect on hunger.
In Africa, there are many more crops that
are grown. I mean, there's sorghum and [INDISTINCT]
some people depend on cassava and some people
depend on bananas. So, you have to have, basically,
like it's the phrase has been filled as a
mosaic. Revolutions. There has to be different
revolution or different parts of the continent.
And I think in Africa, you can have a much
bigger impact than youinitially, if we
just focus on trying to get--teach farmers
how to be good farmers just, you know--I would
say this too that, now we have technology
we didn't have in the '60s, we have biotechnology.
And there are ways to get seeds to the farmers
that are drought--or soon that will be a drought
resistant that will help them in ways they
never had in Asia. So, I don't think you have
to pick or choose. It's just fighting the
right--the modern science to use in Africa.
>> THUROW: Please.
>> So, I have one comment and a question.
The comment was there's also a guy called
Henry Beachell, have you ever heard of him?
He is similar to your guy about the wheat.
He developed a strain of rice, that was very
efficient and saved a billion lives and then
lived to be a hundred years old and died last
year, I read this in his obituary last year
but--so...
>> KILMAN: He was at the Rice Institute in
the Philippines, right?
>> Yeah, exactly, I think so. I mean, that's
all I know about him. But, yeah, they call
him; you talked about the Doha Ran and just
trade in general. Would you agree that farm
subsidies, agricultural subsidies in Europe
and America are probably the single biggest
factor in terms of sort of fixing the economics
of food in the world? And, if so, what do
you think is the sort of that level of awareness
politically because their farm subsidies are
also not benefiting the general consumer,
the general population in North America and
Western Europe as well?
>> THUROW: Yes.
>> So, it's really benefiting 1% of western
population at the expense the whole, the rest
of the world. So, how do you see the political
dynamics? Do you think Doha Ran will be successful?
Do you think farm subsidies will go away in
the west and fix the economics?
>> THUROW: Yeah. I mean, in terms of awareness,
I mean, the politicians are all certainly
and definitely aware of this. It is--the counter
balance to that is the very powerful farm
organizations and farm lobbies in the United
States and in Europe. You know, and that basically
blocks in the way, and we go into this in
quite detail in the book, and kind of a way
the Farmville is almost rigged that it's going
to have the results that it does instead of
dismantling or bringing down the farm subsidies,
you know, to some extent but, you know.
>> KILMAN: But here's to, this is to complicate
though. I'll make it--I never make it easy,
I'm complicated but, we started subsidizing
American farmers in 1930s during the Great
Depression because it's a very efficient way
to fight poverty. Most farms in the United
States in 1930 were poor. That's where the--that
was the epicenter of poverty even during the
Great Depression. And so, we were trying to
figure out, the Roosevelt administration was
trying to get money into the pockets of these
people. And they did it by subsidizing their
crop production. And it was very effective.
It worked. What's--the issue now is that in
this last decade and then this decade, the
average farm family in the United States is
now wealthier than the average U.S. family.
So, does it make it, you know, subsidies are
no longer needed as a--can no longer be justified
as a poverty fighting mechanism. So, one of
the things you have to think about it, you
know, we don't have an issue with, you know,
the $20 or $25 billion--it depends on the
U.S. government spends on subsidizing farmers,
it's--the issue is how do you subsidize it?
If you subsidize per bushel crop production,
if you give them money for every bushel of
crop they produce it, it encourages them to
over produce. And that causes prices to fall
on the international markets and--which means
that farmers that aren't subsidized aren't
protected when prices fall, they really--they
get hurt. So, what's interesting about subsidies
is that overseas and in Africa, it's a huge
issue. I mean, everybody will talk to you
about it; in United States, not so much. We
have plenty of food and not that much of an
issue and we all like farmers. So, you know,
we--do we really want to take money away from
them, why? You know. They don't see it in
that kind of perspective. Our argument is
that, your subsidies are effective way to
fight poverty, if they could justify the 1930s
in the United States, why don't they justify
it in Africa now? What happens is that you
have donors and governments didn't want subsidies
used in Africa. And we think that's--didn't
want farmers to be subsidized there. They
thought it was an inefficient economic policy.
Not good for them, okay for us, not good for
them. We don't think that's right anyway.
>> So, we, a few years ago, we had Jeffrey
Sachs come and speak to us and sort of the
Jeffrey Sachs in the Bono Camp, any other
development economist, I've certain to has,
you know, a lot of concerns about the million
goals and the UNDP and so on. I'm interested
in your thoughts about the UNDP and a million
of the goals and where they factor in to all
of this?
>> KILMAN: Concern meaning whether there'll
be met or are they the right goals?
>> Whether their aims that, you know, are
going to solve some of the problems that you're
talking about.
>> KILMAN: Well, I mean, we know that the
millennium--to us, the most important millennium
development goal was to reduce the prevalence
of hunger by half by 2015. So, in the year
2000, when the development goals formed, you
know, the goal was the World Powers wanted
to see the prevalence of hunger, the percent
of the world that's hungry fall by half by
2015. You know, last year and this year, the
prevalence of hunger actually rose. So, in
the 1970s or early 1970s, nobody has really
good numbers because we didn't really do a
good job counting hungry people back then
but, it's a good guess that 25% of the world
population was chronically malnourished. They
went to bed hungry every night. That's 25%
of the world population. If you want to talk
about the poor nations where you expect to
find hunger, one in three went hungry to bed
every night. By the--a few years ago, you
know, they trended lower, lower, lower, mostly
because the population continued to grow as
the number of hungry stayed the same around
850.
>> THUROW: Million.
>> KILMAN: But now, the numbers of hungry
are growing again; faster than population.
So, for the first time since 1970, the prevalence
of hunger started to grow again. It tried
to pop up. It's impossible that the world
will meet--the World Powers will satisfy their
promise of cutting hunger in half. But as
the World Powers ever had, ever lived up to
their promise to cut to
>> THUROW: Yeah, I mean, even Kofi Annan,
he was the Secretary General at that time,
like he's kind of admitted, they're throwing
in the towel, in not in his efforts because
he's very involved in it, but that's one of
the goals, it is the first goal and that will
be met. I think the beneficial thing of what
the UNDP does and somebody like Bono, is they
at least bring attention to these issues and
say "People, pay attention." One can argue
about you know, the way he used to do what
Jeffrey Sachs, very big on development aid;
the counter argument by William Easterly and
now by Dambisa Moyo, who's kind of repeating
for taking up Easterly's argument, is that,
you know, aid is not the right way to do it.
There's a better financing mechanisms and
things. But the UN, by their efforts and Bono,
it's, at least, this is a problem, people
think about it, let's do something about it
and we can have these arguments which are
very beneficial about how's the best way to
do it. But we've got to think about the--think
about these girls, think about everybody we've
seen in this fight and farmers. And, it's
Norman Borlaug's criminal neglect. And that's
the big movement and cry of them, and particularly,
Bono, that stop neglect. Stop the stupid poverty.
And it's something that we can do--we can
do something about.
>> KILMAN: We're giving long answers.
>> THUROW: Right.
>> So, this is on the topic of outrage and
inspiration and what, you know, the average
American can do. So, do you think--what do
you think is the outrage level of the average
American and how can people who are outraged
get everybody else outraged? And what do you
think is the ability for people to actually
do something that inspires them to say, "I
have made a difference," and do you think
there's--what steps can be taken to make it
because I actually, you know, I'm troubled
by these issues and I don't really know what
do about it. And, you know, how do we get
more people knowing what they can about it?
>> THUROW: Right.
>> KILMAN: I think, I was--do you think I'll
give the, you get the long answer; I'll get
the short one. I think what's what really
intrigues me is that, you know, I believe
there are people out there that have solutions
now and probably your age, they don't know
they have it and I don't know they have it
because they haven't been over there to see
what they know. For example, like one of the
things that are intriguing when I was in Africa
is the difference the cell phones make. That
if you have a cell phone in a village, now
they're connected to the world, and you can
send them prices, and they could start finding
out if they're getting a fair deal from their
local merchant or not. I think another way
that people can make difference is just a
little thing is if you go to Africa and you
know about, and you try to teach people how
democracy works. I mean, one of the things
that intrigues me in Africa is that United
States farmers are very powerful, they're
very powerful lobby. They're 2% of population
but they're certainly can, God bless them.
But, in Africa, farmers are very, very--they
don't have any power but their democracy is
spreading though Africa now. They all have
one vote. They're just what the [INDISTINCT]
realize and "Geez, we could use our votes
to actually elect people who are going to
care about us." But people have, you know,
they don't have that kind of culture, they
don't have that experience. So, now, people
can make a difference through--go ahead, you
can do that sort of thing.
>> THUROW: Yeah. I mean, there's also, also
to marvelous organizations that are very committed
and passionate and involved in this and we
write about a number of them in the book.
I mean, there's all sorts of faith based organizations
across the entire religious phase spectrum.
You know, there's bread for the world. There's
an organization called Food is a Resource,
a bank that's doing very innovative things
in farming communities and it connects people
in American communities, individuals farmers
here and what they can do
>> KILMAN: CARE, World Vision.
>> THUROW: There's CARE, World Vision, the
ONE campaign, you know, they're, at least,
give structure to you and to any others who--and
all the others who are in to this. And I think,
I mean, in terms of your question of the outrage,
I think the outrage is building and we kind
of plot it in the book that, you know, who
basically in the 1990s was interested in the
debt relief issue. That became huge and it
moved, it moved Congress. You know, Jessie
Helms also, to people in Congress, had kind
of, you know, great conversions and they said
they were wrong on foreign aid and things
and so, AIDS. The outcry that was, that was
over the AIDS issue, that all kind of has
come from boil up, boil it up from the grass
roots and what you can see in these organizations,
we kind of implant this history in the book
that it moves kind of from engaging in the
issues. So, the debt relief issue. Well, that
has tremendous impact on the farmers too.
The AIDS issue, a tremendous impact on the
farmers because in 2003, it was the only famine
in Ethiopia; there was huge hunger problems
elsewhere in Africa all the way down to east
coast and in Southern Africa. By 2003, seven
million farmers in Africa died of AIDS; seven
million people not planting crops anymore.
They're are kids, the orphan headed households,
they had no idea how to plant, how to do anything,
how to tend their crops, that spread hunger.
So it became kind of an AIDS-induced famine.
And so, by engagement and these other issues,
it should all eventually come to the hunger
issue.
>> KILMAN: You know, I try to make to the
book is that there really hasn't been [INDISTINCT]
constituency to fight hunger for hunger's
sake, you know. And we try to talk in the
book about why that's necessarily and how
to do that. I know we're running out of time,
but if you--on your other question like the
specific things you can do, you can always
email us, we can up with ideas. I could share,
contact with our people. We have a website,
what's theenough, Enough, the book.
>> THUROW: enoughthebook.com.
>> KILMAN: .com and our email addresses are
on it.
>> THUROW: I also wanted to say that the advocacy
is a great thing, I mean, it's just, you know,
the advocacy with your congress people, with
the senators, even people, you know, the state,
in the state legislatures, you know, to pay
attention to this issue. On the Food Aid,
the Food Aid situation comes up every year
in congress, and that the more that they're
made aware of this, stop, you know, sending
all American food, make it 50%, 50% food of
the Food Aid budget, 50%, 50% cash. They use
all the cash and send more food or something,
but at least have the flexibility to subsidies,
pound home the subsidies issues with your,
you know, with your representatives. The Blue
Nile issue; all these things that we talked
about, I mean, straighten out those things.
The Doha, you know, get on top of the--make
it sure a development round and, you know,
pin down the representatives. You know, we
just had the presidential campaign but it
all stops, you know, few of the questions
even from the moderators on the debates, you
know, what are you going to do about the hunger
situation in the world? You know, it's getting
worse.
>> KILMAN: Looks like you need to wrap up.
So
>> THUMROW: Yup.
>> KILMAN: I'll wrap it, so you have one more--did
you have a question again?
>> Well, let me just cover those, I was going
say the subsidies and sourcing aid locally.
>> THUROW: Right.
>> I would think those are the two biggest
things and those are political things there.
>> THUROW: Right.
>> The Congress, I think, that's the biggest
>> THUROW: Yup. And they're dealing with them
every year. And so, it's when you get a critical
mass and this constituency builds that basically
says for heaven's sakes, let's deal with this
issue. It's an outrage, you know, we should
be all ashamed of ourselves. So, it's the
right thing to do. That's our final pitch
all, I have things to do. Thank you.
>> KILMAN: Thank you.